m
[Musique]
la victoire auxerre c'est votre première
fois qu'anne c'est votre premier film
ah oui c'est vrai dans le film s'appelle
girl oui et dans le film vous êtes une
jeune fille un jeune homme qui devient
qui veut devenir une fille voilà ça
c'est le point commun voyez avec le
personnage c'est que vous êtes danseur
ah oui j'ai touché ses seins jeunes
danseurs merci pour devenir danseur
professionnel en fait
[Musique]
les
oui ça parle donc d'une fille qui naît
dans un corps de garçon qui veut qu'il
veut absolument devenir danseuse mais
c'est un film qui parle aussi de la
relation entre autres cette fille et son
père parce que forcément son père va
beaucoup l'aider donc il la soutient
beaucoup vous n'avez pas hésité parce
que c'est un rôle un rôle très
particulier
[Musique]
remarquable et remarquée dans le cinéma
j'avais envie de jouer le rôle de lara
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment c'est
un peu comme une héroïne
je les admire beaucoup pour son courage
et sa persistance et donc en lisant le
script avec mes parents on a tout de
suite su que ça allait être un projet
qu'il y avait déjà jamais surpasser en
frustrant vendredi au château franc
à tora au caire
je serai donc tous catholiques à mme
noreau tenir avec claudine et ça peu
faste et combustible soit sans doute
scène nationale et après vous invite à
quoi ça m'est donc je sais que comme
j'ai dit j'étudie vraiment pour devenir
danseur et c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui me passionne
mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup aimé jouer
dans le film est donc je reste ouvert à
des projets futurs du cinéma centre et
dans le cinéma par la grande porte en
est également un certain regard
exactement
on va bien pour le film m'a quand même
beaucoup
[Musique]